Hey guys,
welcome back to our
Business English channel.
Today, I want to start
off with a question.
Have you ever felt so busy that you
needed an extra pair of hands?
Have you ever felt the need
to clone yourself?
Well, maybe you need
to delegate more. In this series,
let's look at some top tips
to improve your delegation skills.
First, start small.
Hand over tasks that don't need to be
overseen and tasks that are not paramount
to the completion of your project.
Can you make sure a copy of these gets sent
to all the clients by the end of the week?
Thanks.
Could you just draw up those proposals,
print them out, edit and double check
them, and then just get them ready
and have them sent out to all
the clients by the end of next week?
Thanks.
This allows you the chance to get used to
handing over these responsibilities
and at the same time,
allows your team members a chance
to get used to taking on those tasks.
Next, we need to play
to our team's strengths.
Hey Cara, can you work on our
logo design, please?
Yeah, that's fine.
No problem.
Hey, Cara, can you work
on our logo design, please?
Seriously?
This will not only ensure that your team
members stay happy and motivated,
but handing over tasks to those who have
the necessary skills will also give you
peace of mind that these tasks can be
achieved within your time frame
and to a high enough standard.
Let's stop right there, guys.
We're breaking down the language.
Today we're looking at idioms.
An idiom is when the figurative meaning
of what you are trying to say is different
to the literal meaning
of the phrase that you use.
For example, I have a lot on my plate.
I am not talking about a plate
that has a lot of food on it.
I just mean recently,
I have had a lot of things to do.
I have been very, very busy.
I have had a lot on my plate.
Great, let's jump straight back.
We've broken down the language.
The more you delegate, remember,
at the end, you will end up
with a more well-rounded team.
I want to leave you with another idiom today.
Many hands make light work.
Use your team members.
Delegate those tasks.
It will help you relieve stress and will
free up some time so that you can help
better manage your team's specific needs.
I hope you enjoyed our video today, guys.
Please stay tuned to follow
on for the next series.
If you haven't already,
you can click on the link below
and subscribe to the channel
and feel free to take a look at the rest
of the video series on things like
conflict management by clicking
on the link that you see here.
Thanks for watching.
I will see you next time.